guys fin the kid live for the first time
how many years be uh you know what it's
years 27 years 27 years we are still
doing this damn thing firing kids live
one night only Thursday February 15th at
the Vulcan gas company in Austin Texas
10 p.m. one show only one night only get
your tickets it's going to be good yep
Comedy Club I'll be at the well febru in
Bakersfield with Sam tripley February
23rd the recck room in Huntington Beach
California February 24th and in
Louisville Comedy Club March 1 and get
your tickets let's go and then um that's
it look I want to watch the Super Bowl I
want to make some money tell me what I
got to do please you know this my man
looking for a super offer why I got you
super balll 58 here this Sunday
draftking Sportsbook got you covered new
C can bet on a big game and turn five
bucks into 200 200 instantly in bonus
bets man yeah son's bet on the Gatorade
color there's all sorts of stuff you can
bet on uh I'll take do I do it do I
download the draftking Sportsbook app
and then use code fighter that's right
buddy new customers can bet five bucks
to get 200 instantly and bonus bets only
on draftking Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner the super balll
58 with code Fighter the crown is yours
guys if you have a gambling problem call
1 1800 Gambler or in West Virginia visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 Hope NY or you can text Hope NY 467
369 and Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling as well call
8887895118
again it's the fighter in the kid this
is really the fighter in the kid come on
baby got the great Jim Norton the legend
the house from New York man don't you
like that the legend means you you're
super old the legend really like hear
that yeah anytime you hear that you're
like ah man like I that that makes you
feel like you used to be yeah right
who's a legend David kadine and the way
he went out dude I said that to Damon
Waynes when I saw him at the store I
went what's up Legend I just see on his
like it didn't go well he's like oh cool
yeah it's rough Legend where's where's a
legend go are you another Legend yeah I
I still got stuff to do I'm not done yet
all right what if you say what's up
young Legend yeah better are you how
old's your wife my wife is 26 I'm 55 see
I got I got 34 and you're I'm 57 so
that's outrageous but I really
appreciate it sure do you find last
night I got in trouble because I'm
becoming My Father which means I like to
spend a lot of time in front of a book
or just alone doing something that I
think is workw related yeah so I don't
feel like I'm dying on the vine and she
she put on the
notebook and she this is late at night
though baby's asleep stuff like that
baby did just fallen asleep so she was
mad that I didn't watch The Notebook
with her does she know who she made
correct and I'm like but I got to do
work because I'm trying to pay the bills
I'm trying to figure something out right
now so actually doing work but to her
defense were reading right well no no no
I was doing stuff that was wor that was
work related that was productive but it
was just interesting because she
couldn't understand that I had seen that
movie I don't know when I I I don't care
a also I don't care I it I hated the
[__] blocker guy they're on the date and
the guy's like hanging on the thing
supposed to be Charming while he [__]
blocks this [__] other guy and at the
end I everyone saw it coming wait you're
the guy
[__] old bag everybody knew it was
going to happen I hated that 2004 dude
hated it 2004 that was 20 years ago sir
yeah little little fact about with that
movie they hated each other Ryan go
despised each other on set yeah they
they had to they couldn't be on the like
same set they had to like have different
thing they hat despised each other why I
know that no clue I was just reading
about Brando and rodiger last night
about people that hated each other when
they worked they did on the waterfront
together they couldn't stand each other
really oh Brando is so nuts he refused
to be in the closeup when it was
rodiger's closeup Brando just left so
Rod Stager had to talk to like some
stage assistant and do his big closeup
because Brando didn't have any respect
for Mad ma same way with Tom Hardy and
uh what's a home girl's name oh Charlie
Char yeah couldn't be on the same set
they they' used two doubles really yes
they couldn't be on the Ed Norton told
me a story about he wor he was working
with Marlon Brando Robert denero Ed
score right yeah and Ed Norton is like
this is you know this time he's already
in movie star but Ed Norton's sitting
there like he's a real actor's actor and
just L loved knows everything about film
super smart and there he is working with
[__] Robert dairo two legends and two
legends and he's in the middle of and
they're doing the scene and uh and he's
just he's gu so nervous he's got his
preparation and Brando keeps forgetting
his lines and then finally he gets his
lines and he kind of mumbles like
this and then he sees that dairo he's
looking at dairo and Dao's doing this
Dao's got got to be there and Dao's
doing
this two legends in their in their paf's
[__] asleep and and then he goes okay
cut Dao
goes was I asleep and nor was like he's
like oh these this [__] acting this
is what I got to well that's it is cuz
it's totally comfortable like to be
comfortable enough to doze off while
Marlon Brando is saying anything or
bored or [__] bored that could be
bored yeah you know what I mean he been
on set so many times just another day in
the office watching an obese man try to
remember lines like we got it alcoholic
all right man yeah I met you and The
Godfather too or even have you ever met
anybody that uh had high expectations
and you're like oh man that guy kind of
suck have I expectations of them yeah
not you know what's funny I've had
really good luck like I had a run in
with Jean Simmons many many years ago um
after I had interviewed him on o Anda
and then I bumped into him and he kind
of blew me off and I went crazy on the
air I [__] I was so you know [__]
butt hurt um but then I saw him again
after that an event and he had no memory
of it and he couldn't have been nicer so
that was probably 2004 or five um and
it's been smooth sailing with Jean
Simmons since did you see him with his
wife his ex-wife Shannon they're not
exwife they're still married they're
still married okay they're still married
did you see they did a talk show and she
literally right there said something she
goes uh he said no she's been with me
warts and all through all these all
these years and she said don't call them
warts they're people as in cheating
piece of [__] and he goes ah you know
it's my Osborne's a Savage and she got
up and it was that's not her
name whatever she she get she just got
up in the middle of the inter she goes
I'm done with this [__] you're you're
disgusting and just took her off just
walks off is that legit or was it like a
work or no no that was legit that was a
legit interview where he just sitting
there like well you know messed up
sometimes you [__] around you know warts
and all yeah he did a whole bunch of
cheating yeah whole bunch but he would
talk about it he would always say like
I'm never going to get married and men
are supposed to have sex with a bunch of
like so I think she knew what he was you
can't not know I don't think she's
surpris you married a rock star yeah
well he's he's he's a very interesting
guy smart as [__] multi
multi-millionaire he he was the first
guy to come up that kiss thing was his
invention the merchandise he's just an
incredible business yeah they licensed
the merch yeah incredible businessman
like super smart just a winner in
everything the king and a great family a
great father apparently he's got a great
relationship with his kids and you yeah
I know Nick his son's a really nice guy
yeah and and uh he's done it he won it's
just he's got that thing he's got you
know and he and I let's get his winter
sucked yeah my my midlife crisis by the
way at 55 you know since I can't I don't
have a pistol to shove in my mouth I've
been buying [__] kiss posters like
literally I lost one at an auction
yesterday and I wanted to get back on
the plane and go home to New York I was
so like vintage original kiss posters
yes from Japan I've been I've been out
of my mind this this brand is called
Victor and they have these great [__]
kiss posters they're very hard to find
in really great shape and I've been
spending like I don't buy watches like I
don't I not into jewelry so my midlife
crisis has been kiss posters and I've
been on a bender for like two years
random do do you ever want it so bad you
can't sleep and then when you don't get
does it ever hit you're like what am I
doing every single time I'm there's a
there's a truck I want right now and
it's literally as you're talking it's
all can think of yeah I understand it
really but then I'll be driving like at
a a health scare with my baby girl and I
was trying to get this car and I'm like
what am I who gives this [__] dude
there's so much more important things
and then an hour go by I'm like God I
want that truck but do you guys think
that's are you is this a replacement is
this like a form of procrastination or a
form of like I always think that maybe
wanting you're not it's not the kiss
poster you want it's not the truck you
want something else is going on
psychological no man I want that truck
dude oh no I don't think so oh no yeah
no I do it's dopamine I need a [__]
high I can't drink can't do drugs I'm
I'm not having sex outside the marriage
which I can't [__] believe I'm really
not like I I everyone would say that but
I'm really not and it's an absolute
miracle that I don't cheat like I'm
faithful so it all comes out in one way
like you block up this exit you block up
that exit so it all comes out in his
posters yeah something to chase
something to get something to no longer
feel good about once I have it isn't
that weird yeah yeah then once you get
it that's all right I lost one yesterday
I was [__] homicidal I really was
Furious Furious wait wait wait cuz you
didn't you lost the the bid no I'm going
through this one guy in Japan who uh
like I it's like I have a broker for
[__] kiss posters in Japan and he's
like how much is the max you'll spend
and I gave it to him and I wind up
losing it cuz the max went higher and
I'm like I should have went [__]
higher like I just did they ever tell
you like with the this truck I called
the place and it's in uh it's I won't
tell so people don't look for it but
it's in another state yeah I called the
guys's like we had a guy come look at
today man so hopefully it's here about
I'm like oh man but that's the game it's
the game that's the game that and they
know EX what they're doing you're like a
junkie yeah cuz you're chasing a
sensation that's what you're doing like
in a way you are chasing a sensation and
you just replacing One S sensation for
the next I drove to Connecticut to pick
one up I there's just like original
[__] Casablanca promo poster uh it's
folded cuz it used to go to and it's
it's harder to find in great condition
but I found one in great condition and I
actually drove into Connecticut to pick
it up so it didn't get damaged in the
mail I had some guy driving from Long
Island with a poster what is it about
that I I liked him when I was a kid and
as I get older I can buy most of the
things I want now that's my thing that
the exact cuz you can do it and it's
like yeah it's this weird thing where
you can finally do it and you want
certain things where a kid can afford it
and then now you can it's the and when
you get it you're like on to the next
one yes but I I have a lot of them
framed and put up but literally my wife
wants to [__] pour gas on the hallway
and burn our apartment down it's all
kiss posters She [__] hates it but I
don't care it's like this is the price
of dating me or marrying me this is what
you get you got to deal with vintage
kiss posters vintage kiss posters and
she hates and you'll do whatever it
takes to get the one you want too yeah
but I should have went higher on my bid
I'm annoyed like I didn't realize that I
would have lost it you know what I mean
I would have grew up in New Jersey
Central Jersey where uh North Brunswick
so my hair um I cut my own hair yeah
this next sponsor is not for you I
forgot to tell you turn around turn
around you have a rat tail dude I do
have a rat tail and it's so bad and I
blame my wife she should not let me out
of the house I can't see the back you
know you should probably get now you
solve that problem when your wife
doesn't care about your hair cuz she's
just into my personality you got to go
somewhere to get your haircut go to
Super Cuts go to super I used to go to
Super Cuts all the time actually yeah
check this out talk tell them you can
get a free haircut after this year's big
game if the big game's final score meets
or beats 75 points you could win a free
haircut at at Super Cuts if you register
at Supercuts
high.com and why 75 oh I don't know cuz
Supercuts has been cutting America's
hair since 1975 and 75 just so happens
to be the highest ever score of the game
okay it's going to be tough to beat but
they could get there that's a lot of
points but these two teams can do it so
we're looking for the over on the Super
Cuts high score of 75 points with a
chance to catch a free cut at super cut
salons Nationwide head to Supercuts High
score.com to register read the terms and
conditions and for
eligibility Super Cuts get a super
haircut
want want to score a free haircut
register now at Supercuts highscore
decom visit Supercuts highscore do.com
to register read terms and conditions
for eligibility Supercut register to win
your Supercuts High score.com
Supercuts
high.com um and there it is oh man shout
out to our favorite sponsor ever you're
rocking their sweatshirt I wear mine
nonstop and their jeans I know I need I
need hey our boy Ryan send me the the
the better cut send me the boot cut yeah
they got boot cuts which I'm wearing now
I got to show off these raindrop thighs
yeah they got some tight they got some I
don't need I don't need the booty
Huggers but I need but they'll hug to
you they send me the boot cut like
they're jenos no these will cling to
your body but they're great they're
super stretchy dude that sweatshirt it
looks good even right now dude it's so
comfortable it is the soft P it is so
soft I I make people touch it they go
why is it so soft on the outside so hard
on the inside and I'm like well but also
any shirt that you've seen whether it's
on thick boy.com fireing the kid we only
use true classic shirts that's it that's
all we use what you see me on stage with
yep and you see me rocking the white
shirt all the time black shirts they're
only true classic so now for limit time
you guys can get 25% off look fly all
right 25% off when you shop now when you
go to True classic.com fighter yeah try
the Ultra Soft super stretchy joggers
they are unbelievable oh the joggers are
great you can do a match in hoodie so
you look dope with dope kicks that' be a
fly out it's a great thing to get for
your for your lady yeah or for yourself
and then also Valentine's Day dude you
don't want to look like SL TI on tighter
on the arms and chest but leaves the
perfect amount of room in the midsection
yeah but the true classic buttons ups
are dope there's chinos are cool and you
could rock that for the Valentine's Day
hoodies you seriously can't go wrong
whatever you choose at true classic you
can't go wrong for the big game dress up
man dress dress dress comfortable but
look smart that's what I say they're
underwear they're underwear I wear
nothing but I got the underwear jeans
and sweater on right now yep Brian K
starter pack so if you're ready to
upgrade your closet shop now the
exclusive Link at true classic.com
fighter you get 25% off your first order
no matter how you move make 2024 your
most comfortable year yet with true
classic once again these are the best
shirts on planet Earth the sweater the
jeans the button-ups the chinos up to 25
fly for Valentine's Day the Super Bowl
don't dress like a bum true classic.com
fighter you save up to 25 for your first
order yeah mostly my my wife's from
mortown oh okay yeah I worked I mean I
started in Jersey my whole early part of
my [__] career was in New Jersey I
like it people [__] on it but I like it
n Jersey is as East Coast as it gets
yeah it is when you think about the East
Coast do you think of Jersey I mean you
just do in a lot of ways is is Matt is
is Sarah from uh Jersey too New York
Long Island yeah Matt is a pure Long
Island as long as it gets how's his
brother doing Nikki I don't know Nick I
only know Matt i' I know Nick's name of
course um CU I know other think people
who know him but I don't think I've ever
met him I know Matt I knew Matt would
about back in the day he used to teach
privates and stuff great oh at henzo
yeah I started going to henzo like 8
months ago I probably I wish I would
have started years ago but I didn't so
what you're still doing it now it's very
addicting yeah man and you realize how
bad you are at it and how tiring it is
it's [__] dude it's I've never done
anything more tired try to take a person
with him I mean I mean that's sure for
for for fun if you want to show me
something but I mean what am I going to
roll with him I I've I'm [__] have you
rolled with Matt no even though he wants
me to he's such a good teacher but he's
on Long Island um and I'm in Manhattan
so we just haven't found a time to sync
up but I would love to yeah and you you
and Matt are doing the show how often is
it once a we twice a week we do Monday
and Wednesday like after this I'm going
to run back to the hotel and do a hotel
taping um it's easy it's an hour you
just talking to a guy you love and
people you and fighters who are fun you
know most of them you know do you watch
UFC a lot all the time you do yeah love
it yeah did you watch the dupy uh uh
strictly yeah I thought that uh I
thought dupi got it it was very very
close like I love Strickland so I
wouldn't have been mad if they gave it
to him either I thought he that he eak
it out but then you look at the stats
and I think they actually showed that
Strickland uh yeah I scored it for
Strickland but no one's wrong like when
those fights are so close obviously the
fan bases get so upset but it's like no
one got robbed like you can see how the
judges would give it to dupy like when
you see like Jared Gordon against like
uh Patty pimp you're like yeah won that
Johnny Hendrick GSB like that's
different then the GSP right I hate then
you can get upset then then I get but
then when it's this close like no
there's no it
happens it's fun watching like doing it
on a minor level like I've been doing
because I just take privates with this
guy my schedule but when you realize how
tiring it is the fact that anybody does
that for a living is [__] is amazing
to me dude like I respect it in a way I
I always respected it but just being so
bad at it and such a [__] lump of
[__] white belt rolling around trying to
push somebody off but it's no different
than stand up though like remember when
you started stand how hard stand up to
keep getting up keep doing same as like
you're white belt and stand up you had
open mics eventually two years later
your blue belt you got some bits that
you know will work you know the
eventually you graduate to Purple belt
it's no different but the place that I
train now I'm I'm back into Jiu-Jitsu
and stuff and it this the school there's
mirrors on one side of the dojo and so
like I'm by far the oldest person there
I'm 30 years older than everybody at
least and I I keep seeing myself
compared to all the guys I'm training
with and I don't like it dude it's like
f you just remind there's no older guys
there 100% no except for the teacher
who's 62 yeah uh who's got way more hair
than I do and looks way better but it's
just interesting you're just like what
the [__] am I doing here there's there's
old by the way the kiss poster you just
had up I actually have by wall That's
Japanese Victor poster that they gave
out it's not an attractive poster at all
just I like the old Vibe of it though I
know it's an old school Vibe mine that r
it and they go for some money there oh
yeah um yeah like the mine's like in
that kind of shape it's not in [__]
great shape huh um but yeah I am there's
a lot of older guys at henzo like
there's so many people there there's so
many at and what made you want to get
started now at I've wanted to for years
like Matt's always told me to just go
down and Matt took me there one time and
I know henzo so I knew that I would get
connected with somebody good there and
everyone I've met who does Jiu-Jitsu
have likes like kzo still teaching down
there I he I'm sure he does classes but
I'm only there during the weekdays at a
certain time because I have to get home
and and broadcast so um I've seen him
there like he's last time I saw him
there he was promoting people on a
Saturday um he's the best yeah he's
awesome and does does has to be kind of
weird for Matt because he's he's a coach
right he's best friends with Dana then
like when Al aljo has like an issue like
aljo has a lot of issues the with the
UFC has put Matt Matt an awkward place
probably just he stays out of it which
is a smart thing Matt is really good at
that like he's like we're friends but
like Matt just seems to know like I he
can't there's there's the friendship and
then like Dane is the head of the UFC so
I'm imagining that he just goes hey
whatever his business it has to be
worked out in a business way I've never
seen him get stressed about it though
like I've never seen him and even
privately he's never said anything like
I'll talk to Dan and straight out like
he just seems to have to go through the
same process everybody else yeah don't
don't I think that's a very smart he
probably knows not to step into that
lane but there's also not much he could
do yeah you know I'm like like it's not
it's not on Matt like he don't have the
power to call I'm I'm not saying him D
our best friends he's not like come on
dude cuz it's like that's why Alo has a
manager like the business side like talk
to your a manager dude I'm friends with
both you guys so just talk yeah I I know
somebody who's very well known as an
actor and then there is somebody who is
who is the biggest agent probably owns
you know one of the one of the owners of
the one of the bigger agencies in the
world and my friend has been friends
with him for a long long time they're
close real close and he um he decided
one day he was going to intervene in
something in a decision on behalf of one
of his friends you're going to see why
that guy's a shark and the guy and my
friend who's no pushover my my friend
said dude I tried to I I learned my
lesson so quickly because I said I tried
to kind of get involved and he called me
goes don't you ever [__] ever get
involved in my [__] business don't
ever [__] do that that is not your
place and he was like J it was it was
just you know sounds like a great
friendship I know I know he he was it
was clear like oh dude I stepped into
the wrong water just now but did he ask
him like a friend like he look I don't
know how this work I just wanted to ask
is it possible like they got get mad see
I I've done that cuz my my boys high up
at an agency and this is hilarious and
you guys all know him he's a comic when
the Joker was was announced the Joker
was being made he goes hey man I think
I'd be perfect for this role I but have
you ever acted he goes n done some stuff
but I go dude this like a major like
they're looking at walking you know this
is insane dude he go I know could you
just toss my name in there and I brought
it up as a joke and he was like shot
down I'm like dude it doesn't work like
that like it just doesn't no like these
these there's so many moving Parts like
just because we're buddies and I have a
buddy who controls it he's not going to
put you in as the lead in a major
Universal remember we talked that guy we
talked to a guy who was who had who
worked with the Hell's Angels he did
merchandising and stuff from
I said yes and I don't know if you
remember this conversation I said what's
it like to be around them and he goes
grizzly bears I said what do you mean he
goes they're grizzly bears you as long
as you if you want to work with grizzly
bears you want to photograph grizzly
bears just you can photograph grizzly
bears they might get used to you just
remember you're never a grizzly bear
though right and the minute you forget
you're not a grizzly bear you get
[__] eaten and it's the same idea you
might hang out in their Clubhouse they
might be friends with you you might be
okay the minute you forget you're not a
Hell's Angel some dude from another
chapter comes in he doesn't give a [__]
who you are and if you act if you're
acting in a certain way you're going to
get well that's within it it's like guys
who hang out with Fighters like just cuz
you hang out with a bunch of black belts
doesn't mean you're tough yeah what that
I was referencing you but same with like
just cuz I hang out with Comics doesn't
mean I'm as talented as you by the way
what you should have done with your
friend before I forget is you should
have told him like yeah I talked to the
head of the agency he really likes you
he wants you to email him but if he said
if he doesn't get back you just keep
hitting him up uh and you should have
really
[__] his [__] career he said he's
really excited the prospect send send a
head shot and a video and he want you to
go he says make sure you keep sending
him tapes different tap send a tape send
tape improvise it but make sure you're
in full makeup yeah do scenes as the
Joker but he wants a black scent so make
sure you do it like that a black SC I'm
the Joker make it real stereotypical oh
hell no oh hell no you just really make
sure you seec me on it so I get them too
to make sure you're doing it so I can
blast it out that should be a TV show
that sh right there TV show yeah you
just have your friend what's interesting
about the Hell's Angels though is I
didn't know this I was talking to Hell's
Angels Came the show they make so much
money off merch they're licensing to the
merch in my head I'm like who the [__]
rocking Hell's Angel merch unless you're
a Hell's Angel and who the [__] would
ever do it illegally like do they
actually have a lawyer that deals with
their copyright like who actually going
I had to deal with them yeah we we did a
a something similar like you know how it
says like California and you know what
so we did similar fire and kid thing and
they reached out I'm talking like we've
had Disney come after us ESPN off merch
yeah you don't want the Hell's Angels
going hey like oh okay no problem how
fast do I delete this no but it's not
even like a a scared like muscle Techni
like they're lawyers we on within an
hour when it was posted like what the
hell are you doing like my bad Disney
took a day or two what they say do they
want money because I almost did for chip
chipperson I almost did these uh Marvel
ones but I'm like ah they'll flag it I
just didn't do it anything with like you
can do it if it's a parody that's how
like bar you know how bar stool you'll
be like how can I do a Roger Goodell
face it's a parody like that's how they
get away with it yeah this would have
been kind of a it it's a gray area with
when it's a parody I do it all the time
with merch like the smiley face we had a
thick boy like smiley face you know
there's a family from like the 1960s who
owns the smiley face rights so when you
see like uh Justin Bieber theovon when
you see a smiley face they have to give
percentage of sales to this family wow
so they go cool you can use a smiley
face but we get this much or you can
just pay us a flat fee of this much it
like yeah and the flat fee was so much I
was like I'll just come up with a
different design it's some family owns
the smiley face that's incredible wait
just the circle with the smile Force
Gump did not invent that yep wow that's
really weird is that W I thought it was
just Universal smiley face anybody knows
that's some family's Legacy hey [__]
kid doodled this and we decided to go
and get a who's the basketball coach
that that
patented three Pete Jerry
sanduski sorry always my
go it's got to get off the top of you
tip of your tongue always on the tip of
Jim Jerry hand a [__] no no Jim you got
to get that out of your remember LeBron
tried Patton LeBron tried Patton uh Taco
Tuesday remember that right yeah and
everyone's like no dude you can't no
jeene Simmons patented the money bag
symbol though like you can there are
things that just um I guess weird ways
to make money [__] creative way I
know I know I just I there's nothing I
can think of that things I patented
nobody wanted so nothing I patented
would have any you know pushing Court
nobody gives a [__] God people can just
they'll buy websites too you know like
that we constantly got to stay on it
like squatting it's illegal though isn't
it or or is like can you buy somebody
else's name yeah once it goes up for
sale like there's a like we have
whatever it is fir inthe kid.com we have
it for like six years but we'll they'll
give you a warning like months before
like hey make sure you buy this cuz as
soon as it goes live anybody can buy it
I had to I had to buy uh brian.com from
somebody there was a guy who bought up
everybody who is remotely well known uh
he bought their domain this is 20 years
ago and I I even I paid him ,500 bucks
not bad and I yeah and I texted him I
said uh or I emailed him or something I
can't remember I actually started
talking this is a really interesting
idea he goes dude I've been doing this
forever I've never had to do anything
again it's just like I make so much
money off it it's kind of a scumbag way
but good for you yeah it really is
it's it's it's [__] gross but he just
saw what was happening before anybody
else he goes I'll buy this it's scumbag
move though I bought J norton.com I got
I finally it went up for like it went up
because it was a Toyota dealership
somewhere so there some some guy had it
because it was Jim Norton Toyota and
then it finally went up and I I I took I
wouldn't have paid a lot of money for it
either it's like if you see my ticket
sales [__] you not not spending what
bonus so what bonus yeah we were talking
about that before we just staying
relevant and constantly hustling yeah
well The Game's changed since you guys
got involved right like it's like the
promotion side's almost bigger than the
material side you got to understand
though Jim and I came up and we had a
whole We There was an industry that did
it all for you it just they all you had
to do the promotions you talking about
you rely on the club to put a banner all
of it but now your agents your managers
yeah but now it's like you could do that
no but but you have to take control of
it like you look at like what Schultz's
doing you look at theano Chrysler's the
the epitome of it you know I'm not
saying the material is bad I'm saying
there's guys who aren't a fraction of
good as stand-ups as you are but sell
tickets cuz they're good at the
promotional side what I like to do I
find what's really effective is I just
put up a banner where it's not a good
picture of me with dates on it and I say
let it just fade into nothingness uh and
it's really great it motivates no one to
come to show just a picture of you like
this yeah yeah Jim Peak and 07 Norton
that should be my [__] my Nick name
p07 Norton yeah you got to be realistic
about these things do do you do you have
trouble writing or do you still writing
a lot I always write on stage I know
saying that makes me sound like such a
douchebag but it's just the way I've
always been good at like talking through
an idea um on stage and just playing
with it CU you again you're on there I'm
doing two sets a night I thought that
was one of your best promot I see all
your stuff obviously Jim but one of your
promotional things you did you were
doing a bid on stage and you messed it
up and it went nowhere and you're like
tickets at blah blah blah but it was
like so authentic and no one posts you
know when they do bad or if it flubbed a
line like I I forget what I was only
posting bomb Clips at yeah he he's only
posting bombs it was great have you seen
this Brian Holtzman I love Brian Holzman
you see what he's posting now no he's
posting people walking out of his shows
[__] that guy [__] you
guys for they're all losing their mind
[__] He's insulting he's it's great
and they're like well I think he'd like
to hear that there's a certain clientele
that's going to see that like oh yeah
that's my guy yeah I like this guy yeah
you can turn anything into any failure
into success if you I'll tell what you
can't though bombing Clips do do not
turn into success believe me when I tell
you yeah I thought about I think I think
Mo most Comics enjoyed it but I was like
I wonder if the fans like no they didn't
care funny anymore dude Comics Club I I
was I loved it dude I went I did the
frier club one million years ago I
remember and uh I said to my buddies who
was there it was gillo and my buddy
Gavin oconor who's a big director and
did the accountant and stuff and and
then my buddy Johnny and uh and then
couple other guys and I said uh we were
eating at mastros and I Saidi got to do
a set they go you do and I go at the
frier club like and I go I'm gonna do 40
minutes and it's just GNA be bird humor
because I had 40 minutes on birds I go
it's gonna just be bird humor and I'm
going hard and I'm going to do it slow
and deliberate I hope you enjoy this
dude I did I'm [__] dying I'm doing
bird comedy the penguin everything oh
dude I go I'm one of the top bird
humorist in the country guys so this is
a sorry sorry if it's bird heavy it's
just I'm I'm an Avan sorry if it's bird
Sor it's bird heavy I'm an Aven
Enthusiast what's the deal with
ostriches it's like no one ever Sor it's
bird heavy the comics and my friends
are like laughing so hard not audience I
heard just silver
chain like looking at me like this there
was a girl who liked me uh we had kind
gone on a date and she was with people
and she was just looking at me like this
I she had she was like I don't like this
guy she couldn't have blown me off
harder my friends in the comics back
there and then red buttons remember red
buttons the great red buttons like one
of the greatest came out to me and goes
you got a lot of imagination and you're
going to go a long way in this racket
kid I was so impressed you didn't let
them bother you at all he was [__]
loving it I was like hey hey I go thanks
guys that's my bird humor for for today
um I'll see you next week enjoy dud we
had a comic at The Improv it was a sh
and he's all excited cuz he had these
two girls in the front row he goes out
bombs eats all the dicks and come he's
like oh man I don't know man just the
crowd's not feeling I'm like yeah the
Mater was tough dude and then he looks
at he goes ah [__] she's leaving dude
like girl left yeah she left cuz he just
ate
[__] that's a hard gig like I did one
set there I remember I forget what it
was for but I remember Donnie Most from
happy days was in the audience and I
really wanted a picture with Donnie Mo
from Happy Days Ralph MF and I [__]
ate my dick and I was like I I was too
embarrassed to go over and talk to him
yeah there he is Don most now hey who
who the guy we playing that casino in
Vegas oh Johnny Walker Johnny Walker
Johnny Walker so the fighter no Johnny
walk good times from Good Times Jimmy
walk Jimmy Jimmy Walker sure yeah D
might so I'm younger I don't know who he
is and they we wanted to book our host
or feature they no we use the same guy
every time you're going to use uh Jimmy
Walker like all right whatever we get
there I don't know who he is Brian's
like dude that guy was a big deal a
while ago like all right he refused to
look at us and then finally I'm like hey
man so do you want to like go over like
the set or whatever where how much time
are you going to do he go nah son I've
been doing this a long time I got it I
got it you guys do your thing I'll bring
you up I'm like all right whatever and
then he won't talk to us so I go but he
was he was funny he was funny but I go I
go Brian let's go talk to him at least
it's uncomfortable in the green room so
we go over and he's not looking at us he
goes I've been doing this about 50 years
I've seen everybody never heard of you
twoo and I was like okay all right well
he goes I'll see you out there the best
was he goes like this he goes um he said
uh they showed me the poster you guys
and I
said
yikes it's the first thing he said I was
like I don't know what yikes means and
he goes anyway I worked with David
Letterman I don't know if you ever heard
of him right he just he was funny he was
joking around with that but I don't I
couldn't figure out if he was [__]
and then he gets up and does stand up
and and it's not bad I mean he it was it
was our crowd our and then Brendon goes
up there to go shake his hand he goes
don't touch me and then I was like oh
and then I got on the mic and roasted
him right cuz he was selling the CDs
yeah said make sure you get your Jimmy
Walker CDs on the way out everybody he
had signed 8 by10 let's be honest it's
not exactly a Love Fest two minutes ago
you guys said Johnny
Walker he said Johnny no but it's fine
it's like you guys won I mean all these
years later he was on Good Times in 76
and you're like that John Walker kid
you're like Jimmy Walker I my feeling
though is that he's he's actually loves
to play around and he's he probably
[__] around I think so I actually
think he's yeah I I actually ended up
thinking I think he was just [__]
with us and I miss the joke I met I met
him he hosted or he was he was on a the
Louis Anderson show I did we were on the
same episode it's like the weekend I met
dice in 97 and I think he was on the
episode with me he was very he does look
really great he's an older guy funny too
he's smart he was very nice but I but
again I I talk to everyone's nice on of
TV taping like usually when everyone
else is everyone's nervous no one wants
to be a dick like you're to Montreal no
one's a [__] [__] on those tapings
CU everyone's panicking yeah so what
you're doing this uh YouTube show with
your wife yes what's it called it's just
Nikki and Jim NYC it's our Channel and
and what do you guys do just slice the
lifestyle it's just pieces of our life
yeah it's it's one of those things where
it's like I can't watch myself uh you
bring it up to H just I can't watch any
you're exactly like me trying to you
promoting you self-promoting is it's
like cuz you're Irish it's like so
anti-irish it's like the idea that
you're Irish right Am I Wrong uh yes I
can't do it though it's like when you're
Irish from Jersey no I can't watch I
can't watch me okay so I can't watch me
I can't watch me I can't watch me it's
almost like a vlog is kind that's all it
is yeah that's all it is it's just she
and I together just little pieces of our
life and uh you how' you meet her um she
Facebooked me uh and then I kind of
became uh very into her very quickly
after that cuz she was uh naked on
camera but she Facebooked me cuz I talk
she's transgender I talk about trans
women in my Act and she lik so she was a
man now she's a woman yes she was born
male yeah you never cease to amaze me
Jim Norton oh yeah I mean we've been
married for two years I mean uh F yeah
she's great my buddy said to me he goes
uh he's very straight guy and he goes I
want to have sex with a transgender
woman and I go okay he goes I just want
to see what it's like I want to see if
it's better than the real thing and I
said okay you're might you're a little
bit gay right yeah you're you're not
straight I mean I being a homosexual is
different but and I guys are like Jim
you're delusional I'm like you're not
straight if you have somebody who's
trans and they have a dick I don't think
you're straight you call yourself what
you want I don't care so she is fully
transitioned no oh no no okay so so
you're a little gay it's have you always
been a little bit I mean sure I mean I
talked about monster R in 2007 on HBO I
blew all my friends when I was a kid I
mean I mean that's it's old hat at this
point yeah I've been talking about I
know this about you oh my god oh this is
Fu even I knew this oh really I've been
talking about for 20 years we're all
busy I mean you know everyone's doing
their thing hey Bri how many tickets I
sold Jim blew his friends when he was a
kid all right but how many tickets we're
busy we're doing things Fu great Jim God
I love you thank you I love you yeah
yeah I but as a kid you were just
curious about it and you started blowing
your friends was that the first time I
mean it's it's not even C you just kind
of fall into it like I don't remember I
mean I like girls too you falling a [__]
yeah you did you just kind of lean over
you're yawning and there it is happens
blowing your friend you're like that
wasn't bad you're wrestling somebody's
[__] flies out of his Speedo it's like
what there we go what am I going to do
be rude can't you get to put it back in
his pants when it's hard but I was I
think I was bullied when I was a kid I
used to blow this kid who used to pick
on me but then there was other kids who
I just was friends with and we would do
it so yeah like to be with somebody
who's who has actively has a penis yeah
um there's guys who like they want to
have this whole thing of you're totally
straight because they have a certain
narrative they push yeah but it's hard
to say that it's like I I think that
you're these progressives who want to
tell you that you're straight uh they're
not as Progressive as they think they're
actually married to the 1950s idea that
straight is the right answer so we have
to find a way to make anything you're
doing hetero it's like that's a 1950s
thought I just don't think you're
straight but you have you have such a
bro following right don't you think and
and did that what was that like when you
told them that was their backlash I mean
not that you read comments where people
like giv a [__] I mean like I've been
talking about it for so long like
literally over 20 years so any body like
especially if they were a fan anybody
who doesn't know um has literally had
their radio turned off since 2004 I mean
i' you've always been I've always I said
that you've always been the most
transparent honest [__] on the
planet which is what part part of what I
love about you as a comic too but thank
you and as a person I mean I you know we
don't know each other well but I always
knew the one thing about you is that you
are as authentic as a get I mean I
question the friendship now you know he
blew kids in high school yeah then again
we lived in different dist I know yeah I
was going to say I mean I can't I can't
bring into my inner circle you
understand oh I understand I know cuz I
put the cracker on the floor I know no
it's not so so you so you met this that
you met your wife yes and and was
watching her him I don't know how her
yeah her but I understand but there's a
whole thing of her and him I mean people
will say like him or she's a guy like I
I I mean I know that usually when people
say that they're trying to be shitty and
they're allowed to be shitty if they
want to but met uh she had sent me a
quick Facebook message because I talk
about this stuff in interviews and I've
gotten a lot of messages from trans
girls because I talk about it and a lot
of guys don't so they're always like hey
thanks for staying that or I'm so happy
that you're comfortable talking uh she's
gorgeous oh thank you yeah and she's
funny and uh we you know she's my best
friend I have a great relationship with
her um and what when did she decide to
transition she's still intact but I want
to say 12 years ago or whatever did she
take estrogen uh yes so yeah she takes
her pills every day okay and then but
she still has other things a dick yeah
she has yeah which is that is amazing
yeah I mean it's just very attractive
human being I have to say well thank you
yeah and she's uh all the way around
yeah I just uh we we match well because
again she's not fragile her personality
is she's very headstrong she's you know
I respect her opinions on things we
don't always agree but she's uh she's
very comfortable stating an opinion that
nobody is going to like and she liked
you because of your comedy she just
wanted she's Norwegian so they're very
literal people like you know what I mean
like not good to dirty talk with you
know what I mean like you know like hey
I'd love to watch you [__] somebody
else you wouldn't like that I know I'm
being [__] dirty uh it's like the
literal
[__] um literal she's very linear
very lit very linear but she likes the
comedy uh I talk about our us a lot uh
in the in our act I talk about her as a
person I talk about the SE ual stuff and
she loves it like she's so not shy about
it she has no shame and I like that like
how long she been transitioning again I
want to say about 12 years it was long
before I met her um before this became
fashionable yeah yeah and that's what I
always like you know now it's in a
Zeitgeist and everybody knows about it
and people talk about it but when when I
first became aware of it was I was 15
like I was it was 1983 and I was
watching porn with my friends like I
didn't know it existed wow um so you
know it turn when you saw it on on porn
it turned you on it it [__] all my
friends were like that's disgusting and
I was like yeah but I made a mental note
I'm like aha I didn't know what it meant
but it meant something and that's how it
works I didn't know what it what but not
men so men men don't excite you the way
I've had sex with men but it's not what
I want there's no love there it was
purely I think Addictive Behavior Uh but
the idea of like holding like a kissing
a man like like and like I find that as
uncomfortable as any of my male friends
would would find it with me like I love
Bob Kelly but I wouldn't jerk him off if
it would sa his life yeah yeah yeah but
a guy kissing a guy with a beard is not
no I mean look socially I have no
problem with it but it does it does this
it I feel the same way about it sexually
that you would probably feel the same
way about it sexually it doesn't move me
in any Iota and that's not because I
don't want it to it just doesn't never
but then but then but somebody who's
feminine with a dick it depends on the
person like I like women you're
complicated no it's it's really most
people have I think you're making more
complicated most people have different
nuances in what they like look we all
have our sexual stuff right like
straight guys you like what you like and
whatever it is some of it's like very in
andout and some of it's probably real
private I don't care if people have
private sexual stuff everyone does yeah
but when men who like trans girls don't
even admit that they like them it's like
you're letting this whole group of
people just sit there and you won't
acknowledge I think my friend is that
way I think my friend won't admit it but
I think he dates women and loves women
but I think he's got a thing for Trans
men or trans women something about it do
I know I don't think so but there's
something about it that that that I was
very surprised at because he couldn't be
straighter quote unquote yeah but
there's a thing that's going on there
for him sure and there's a lot of guys
like that and they just don't and again
I'm not saying you have to reveal your
private sexual desires because everyone
has them but to it's almost like saying
you know if you like one group of people
and just deny that that whole group of
people does anything for you and you see
them like getting treated like [__] and
talked about like their [__] you don't
have to jump in socially and change the
world but you can at least go yeah well
I'm I'm very attracted I like trans girl
like you were probably sexualized with
uh the same sex when you were younger as
a straight boy and that felt good and so
or just I don't think I was a straight
boy though like you never no I I don't
know because again maybe I was sex my
therapist tells me I was molested I'm
like I showed up it felt good I like
blowing my friends I like getting blown
we're all the same AG
forcing to keep going back yeah come on
people want to pathologize or traumatize
it but it's not no no I don't if it was
maybe by the classic definition there
was a kid that I was terrified of uh who
I would blow and I could smell the moth
balls in his Budweiser shorts um he was
he always wore Bud weather bathing
trunks mothballs yeah yeah it smelled
like mothballs very strange old lady
family he had but uh yeah I didn't uh I
can't pretend I was victimized by it I
think it's just my makeup it was my
nature you like
I I think you're one of the only guys
too like you're not defined by it right
like I didn't think about it I've known
it for a while I didn't like when you go
on shows like most people that's what
they identify they're come they're going
to come on and talk about being married
to a trans person no it's my life being
married I'm sorry being married is the
crazy part for me like we don't just sit
around and talk about her being
transgender it's like I don't wake up
every day how is your journey like she's
my [__] wife like you know it's like
hey go to the store I went yesterday
it's the same [__] everybody fights
about um but no I don't have an agenda
with it but you can't in anything like
with standup like there's an old
expression if you're okay with it the
audience is okay with it um and you have
to be willing for some people to not be
okay with it um and I just don't care
who's okay with have have you had
anybody probably not in the comedy
Circle but family anybody who's not okay
with it luckily no my family's great my
mom my dad my sister they're very very
uh they were very accepting great um but
if they weren't but they had you as a
son you're you you resonate at a
different tempo just as a comic you
you've always had that wonderful Misfit
energy which I think is kind of a must
if you want to be a comic worth yourself
you got to come there's got to even if
you don't come from dysfunction you got
to create your own dysfunction but still
his dad was probably born in what the
40s my
dad yeah he didn't mind I mean my
parents again they were open-minded
people they weren't my dad they retired
my dad was military he was uh he was in
the Marines in the 60s was a command
sergeant major in the Army he worked for
the Post
dude my mom was a librarian uh but they
were very realistic people they knew who
their son was I mean uh you know your
parents always know oh they do um and
again anybody who was in my life who
didn't like it or who didn't accept
Nikki as my partner my wife get the [__]
out of my life like I don't have to have
an aggressive falling out but I'm fine
cutting anybody off uh I I won't be
friends with somebody who has trouble
with the truth I don't give a [__] like
it's it's I'm 55 years old why would you
though you can't that's the other good
about being older yes like you start to
realize I don't need you man it's like I
got my I got my my friends I got my
family I got my kids I got it's like
there are people out there that will
disappoint you or surprise you with how
callous they can be you also only have
bandwidth for so many people like the
people that text me it's always drama
I'm like I'm good man I'm done with this
I'm done with the energy yeah yeah it's
very it gets to be very draining when
you engage it like and it's not that I
think I'm too good for it it's just like
I just don't enjoy it no like I If
somebody heckles me in a club I enjoy
that because you can be really mean to
somebody who has to just sit there
around other people who've just seen
them be humiliated like that's
satisfying yes but any of the other
stuff like we knew we were going to get
a lot of hate I don't care about that
like you oh you're a [__] all right
good so what like that it's meaningless
oh no that's a terrible thing to say um
but it's been surprisingly people have
been much cooler than I would have
thought like it's been much nicer than I
thought um so yeah I also don't I think
you're different too where you don't
throw it in everybody's face like I
didn't think about it I was like oh yeah
for me what happens when I hear that
maybe because I'm just older and I know
you is I'm like of course that makes
sense it's fantastic it just add another
layer of color Jim Norton well you have
to know like what you're like I'm a
comedian my job is not to teach lessons
I don't [__] teach lessons I'm not I
don't educate people about trans people
I'm not an expert I just I'm in love
with somebody and we're married and
that's it and if you go around teaching
people lessons on stage it's [__]
boring nobody wants to be scolded or
talked at and you know what you have to
do I don't care who you vote for make me
laugh exactly make a point through your
joke great but my job is not to scold
people and uh and tisk tisk them uh I
because I just don't care how they feel
about it I think everybody likes to
laugh I think and everybody needs it you
know there's enough seriousness out
there in the [__] world I think
that's something about laughter when
you're at watching somebody crush a room
you forget you forget all the things
that make you human you forget you have
to go to the bathroom you forget you
have to make money you forget your
wife's cheating on you you forget get
your job me and J J think about kiss I'm
thinking about trucks hear you that
doesn't go away
that's that never that never leaves your
head it it is always kind of just there
like an odor in the room the [__]
kiss Victor post I'm thinking of it the
whole timec je Paul so what's the what's
the holy gra for you kiss poster wise I
I I got like which was the original
Casablanca promo poster I got that you
mean for the movie Casablanca no no no
casablanc kiss caanka record sorry their
original poster from 74 um that goes for
how much I picked 3,000 for which is
again it's not that's not crazy no no no
these These are never going to be like
[__] they're not $20,000 items it's
it's a hobby that you can spend a decent
amount of money on but it's not going to
break you if you're working and you have
a decent uh work life but it's not like
Rolexes it's not yeah Rolex that's the
one it's the second one in there yeah
the original uh I remember that poster
no not that one no that's I remember
that I remember that poster right there
that one's just a print but that he has
the original of that c i original I had
that poster on my wall uh that when you
were a kid oh yeah yeah and there's like
some of the Japanese Victor posters are
kind of Holy Grail items for me now but
the Holy Grail moves because it's about
the addiction of just getting stuff you
know it's it's not Japanese are great
collectors aren't they dude they have
great great their kiss posters are weird
like uh they're they they're like weird
Old Stage shots they're like weird
moments in time like they had these kiss
posters on rice paper and they're just
strange moments that have been captured
yeah like I have a couple of those like
I just the kiss crew is weird like not
weird obviously you know legendary but
when you look back on them like you look
at all the makeup and what they were
wearing and stuff like my kids were I
was watching an old kiss video like
Daddy are those women I'm like no it's
what they did back then it's what they
did it was androgyny in a real yeah they
were gender Benders it was glamrock but
they were more Rocky Horror Rocky Horror
was one of the greatest movies of all
time I mean absolutely they were
definitely more masculine like did oh
yeah Jean definitely Paul had kind of
like the the performer energy he was gay
I think Paul Paul Stanley's actually gay
in real life is he's married with kid I
mean I don't know if he is but he's
definitely married his son performer
sorry Paul um hey man he used to work
out of gold oh did he he's in good shape
oh yeah I was probably in love with him
when I was a kid and didn't know it
because he sang you know it's the star
child amazing you even look at like MC
Jagger like the way he moves and some of
the [__] he wore in the DAV Bo didn't
they have sex yeah yeah yes and by the
way Robert Plant used to wear the the
clothes bring up Robert FL in the 70s
Robert used to wear the clothing of the
women he had sex with the night before
that's what he would do
put on their he put on their blouse look
at look at that [__] he'd wear things if
they were too small for him and he would
just wear that he'd wear that shirt it's
like even Lenny cravit Lenny Kravitz
last night at the Grammys he was wearing
like this like seethrough thing here and
these tight leather pants my wife is
like man he looks cool I'm like you know
how ridiculous I would look if I put
that on yeah nobody that that nobody
more influential as a rock star than him
every 80s every 80s singer from Axel
Rose to mle crew to Vince whatever is
every one of them copied
him voices and they wore their hair long
like that every single one of them
nobody was like them they're still
astonishing Le Zeppelin's still the most
astonishing band in my opinion heavy
metal rock and roll I was I was much
more of a Sabbath fan but when Robert
Plant was doing solo stuff he was doing
something for Serius XM so actually me
and Opie from Opie and Anthony were
sitting in a room probably a little
bigger than this and he was going to do
something for serious listeners and we
were probably from here to to these guys
away from Robert Plant and he was just
like going through his set me and Opie
were the only guys watching him because
it was a warmup so he got to sit there
and watch him he was doing some Zeppelin
he was doing some uh new it really was
pretty amazing Legend yeah to watch him
I mean that close felt and and uh at s
speaking of sarus you you've been on
there for how long it'll be 20 years
excuse me at the end of this um at the
end of this contract which is one more
year when I think of s I think of you
and then Howard Stern I don't really
know any but like rude judee's out of
there is gone yeah Jude's great Ellis is
gone Jason I love Jason Ellis Jason's
great um sway has a good show uh excuse
me that's lovely um who kid has a show
uh you know he's 50 cents DJ he's really
funny there's some good shows on there
but I don't listen to anything including
my own show I just do it and then leave
anything I do I just ignore unless I'm
editing it and like are the videos I do
with my wife we edit and then once
they're up I never again you know how to
edit that [__] wow I mean I have someone
who's better like I can just get like
funny beats and funny moments or M I
think funny but as far as the
technicality part of it no I just chop
it an iMovie and send it some do you see
Howard at the at the do you go into that
serious oh yeah I'm there cuz Howard was
doing it from his home right for a hot
second yeah I've met Howard a couple
times there we don't know each other um
I think I've met his wife more than him
um weird cuz he's been there like you
two are the Staples of s we are but we
go in different Studios like Howard's on
one side and like around the early two
like 20078 n Ry was on his show and I
was on OPI and Anthony and I would just
bump into you know four mornings a week
in the elevator uh I do too how's he
doing I haven't talked to him but I hear
he's doing well which I'm happy for too
but I would I you know I was up all
night [__] I just don't sleep well
and Arty was doing heroin and we were
making it in at the same time uh it was
so funny he'd have his sunglasses on and
I always loved him and then and in the
morning the two shows were kind of
Rivals and go right I'll see you later
and he was just going to Howard and I
would go to O Anda but it was great
already I've always said after being in
this business for 30 years I already in
many ways cuz I worked with them on Matt
TV for two years all right I I have
never uh I don't think I've ever met
anybody who was naturally that funny and
that good at improv that that his
ability to just come up with things out
of the blue I've it's never ceased to
amaze me he could improvise a song he
would start improvising a song and it
just and like he could do it right there
and rhyme it and just I I I never saw
anything like it yeah I love him I
haven't seen him in a while he had
stepped aside and was like taking time
for himself and then a few years ago I
was doing this tour with a bunch of
other comedians uh and you know it was
like antisocial it was called it was
like myself and and Stan hope did a few
and bird did a few umel did a bunch of
them and Arty came on and did a few and
uh it was like his first standup back
and uh he's just he's very loved like
people love Arty Lang there's something
very genuine about him uh again he shows
you everything you see the good the bad
the ugly the successes the failures um
he's he's no shame about who he is as a
human being and I think that's why
people just connect with he's amazing
he's authentic yeah I love him yeah and
and you you have no plans to ever leave
do you live in New York I live in New
York and I I don't want to leave it um
again my wife likes it out here and I
like it to come out and visit like I
love coming out here and I used to hate
it because you think you're supposed to
as a dickheaded younger New York Comic
like I'm [__] I'm real so is
everybody out here I just I don't like
the [__] uh I get fat and lazy when
I'm out here compared to New York I can
walk to the seller every night and walk
home so I kind of like that ecosystem to
be in and didn't didn't The Comedy Store
just pass you they you know it's so
funny I saw a post I know I I what I I I
I haven't been on there in a long time I
like those guys I went in there and saw
prior there in '95 I was out here with
it was like one of our first La trips
when uh Carolines was managing people
and I came out Patrice myself J.R havin
and a couple of other guys and Richard
was on so that's how long I've been
going to the store and uh I've done sets
there mity saw me there and said I could
do sets but I guess I wasn't a past
regular um you just weren't living here
and you weren't yeah yeah I didn't I
didn't take it personally I just I was
never out here so um they were always
very generous to me when I came out all
the clubs were they were always like if
you want to go on let us know uh they
were very generous um but yeah I read
that and I saw that I'm like oh wow yeah
I was kind of were you close to Patrice
it was one of my closest friends yeah
wow oh yeah we went to Brazil three
times together I spent a lot of time
with Patrice so smart he was and that
was the worst mistake people could make
about Patrice cuzz he was loud and he
was silly and he was obnoxious but he
was also a brilliant guy and people who
would get into it with him who thought
like oh this is just a big fat loud guy
found out very quickly like he's going
to slice you open down the middle can
you imagine if they had podcasting now
for cuz he was like always kind of anti
Hollywood he was always like anti
Hollywood but if think about the fan
base he would have if he was on his own
his own BG thing he would have been
amazing yeah he he he sat me down was
with Dove and I I you know knew him a
little bit like tiny bit like here and
there but we sat down and he started
talking about the difference between men
and women and
relationships
and I didn't even know what to say I'd
never heard anybody break down and my my
mouth was a little open and I looked at
Dove and Dove goes he drops a heavy
truth I told you he drops a heavy truth
do is another one who smart as [__] my
God one my favorite human beings on yeah
me too I love I see we do davidov is uh
one of the great Comics really funny and
uh a great guy like just a very solid
person he always looks like he's
thinking about something else though
like whenever I say hello to Dove I'm
always like all right I'm pulling you
out of whatever thought you're in right
now cuz he's always he always looks like
he's debating something and it's a great
way to describe Dove yeah but very funny
and he walks on stage and he I don't
think I've ever seen Dove not do well on
stage he's really good so good say
things like that they were talking about
Manny Pacquiao and how Manny Pacquiao
used to and we're all of us were all
sitting around we're watching this this
expose on Manny Pacquiao and and he's
got his girl there Do's got his girl
there and and he could never sits still
and he's just listening and they're
talking about how hard it was for Manny
Pacquiao because as a kid he sold fans
that he had to make out of feathers from
pigeons he caught and what [__]
impossible way of growing and then he
fought his way up to five weight classes
and it was just this towering epic life
of a guy who came from the center of the
earth and just you know and it's just
like the music and [__] there's a
pause and Dove goes yeah f [__] make
fans on the streets in Philippines
[__] try monogamy
sometimes he just leave the room do the
best and his girlfriend's like the [__]
do the best this is what I have to be
married to yeah do the he I to piss real
quick I I got a p to I got to pee like
desperately okay cool thank you I love
podcasting wrap it up no no I'm a no I I
really have to pee me too uh guys when
it comes to macadamia nuts the most
delicious nuts on the planet you dud and
you're a nut expert you've always love
nuts we've always said that about Brian
we go what's the one thing Brian loves
nuts in his mouth I like some some
buttery good for you nuts with omega-7
fatty acids don't know what that means
but apparently it's good for longevity
either way here's the thing macademia
nuts usually you buy a pack it's your
house payments they're so expensive not
so with House of macadamias they have
cornered that market they work with like
90 farmers in South Africa part .ous of
mamas.com
TFK you can get your favorite bundle get
free snack bars every time with 15% off
the whole order plus certain bundles
come with bonus goodies like free
Macadamia milk and free shipping uh
change up your macademia subscription at
any time no strings attached and you can
pause or cancel at any time but get
those nuts they are ridiculously
delicious it's also a great gift
everybody loves macadamia nuts wife
couldn't get into the country for 5
years yeah it was a long immigration
process she trans uh no no no they that
that she's just Norwegian nor you know
Norwegian terrorist she was coming
through and they FR her they're like
what the [__] is this and they sent her
back home packing heat yeah no she had a
minor marijuana chart like I mean it was
a uh a text message about uh she asked
somebody about smoking hash and her this
is true and her friend got arrested for
some other matter and they looked
through her phone and found the text
message my wife was 18 when she sent it
it was like the craziest thing why
didn't she just come illegally through
the Border like everybody else dude the
rage cuz Biden wasn't president when I
was [__] going to see her in Canada
like it's a long story but I I I put her
in Canada from Norway uh during the
immigration process we were she had been
rejected four times and I would always
think about sneaking her home in my
trunk I'm like she would have been in
the country already which she would have
but I you get angry at people uh but I
also have empathy for people coming
across the border like like I I don't
agree with it because it took us 5 years
but I also am really fortunate I have
money for a good lawyer uh who can
navigate Homeland Security and all this
nonsense and layer after layer after lay
but like I understand the emotion of
hopping over I'm not saying I agree with
it but like having I I used to think
she'll never get in I'm not going to
have my life like this is the person I
want to spend my life with and it's not
going to happen so it was was horrible
depression on and off for 5 years so
people who cross illegally are wrong but
I also I'm like I get why you want to
because dude this is a movie it's it was
so [__] a movie by the way don't
think for a second Jim that I'm not
going to be watching this TV show and I
wouldn't have watched it if she wasn't
trans how about that it's interesting to
me now it adds a layer of interest I'm
not to you and it's probably wrong that
I would say that because she's a human
being and just happens to be that it's
the problem I'm gay okay I'm a I'm a
regular person who happens to be
attracted to the same sex in some
instances you're watching she piece of
[__] that's right I'm going to watch it
no I just adds a layer of color to Jim
so of course now I'm going to watch it
for J no I'm going to watch it for Jim
but but it just it adds that layer of
color now I'm like of course this all
makes sense this is fantastic so yeah
know it is it is obviously it's what
makes us different as a couple but we
are a same couple like like most people
but of course that's what's different
about us um I think people will like it
if they watch it I think there's there's
some funny moments in it it's not
preachy at all um and we've been very
careful to not be because I hate when
people preach at me it never converts me
it never changes can I ask some if it's
offensive tell me [__] off ask me
anything when you guys fight do you
fight like uh like a normal couple or
because she used to be a man do you
fight like dudes any I'm saying 100%
yeah weird to argue with her it it is
like every woman I've ever argued with
there is not an ounce of male in her
emotionalism when she argues really it
is it of the the soul and brain of a
female and I I know that that's sounds
crazy and people think I'm polluting
myself5 if I was [__] if I like if I
like you guys I would tell you but I
really her [__] brain is the brain of
a woman there's no and again I
understand what the comments will be
coming back no I would but I think
that's where people get confused like I
I think there is a thing where it's just
people are born that way the wiring is
what it is and that's how they are and
then there's also this movement of
people that now it's like the hot thing
to do and they're lost so they get
pushed in that direction
but yeah you your transgenderism a real
thing like I think someone like Bruce
Jenner or your wife I mean that that's
there I know somebody who transitioned
back in 95 who worked on my show on Mad
TV she was a hairstylist but but but
Michelle was taking her sister's birth
control pills when she was a boy at 14
she was always a girl you it's a weird
thing like yeah like the thing that's
weird is like there are people who who
just are confused in life and claim that
because they think it's an identity and
then there are people who really are
transgender that's cuz it's an option
now like even when I was a kid that was
not an option it's like any other thing
in life any other any other group of
people in life any other thing in life
you have people that are genuine and
it's who they are people who are conf I
don't know who's who I I know my wife is
who she is I think the people that use
it as like an out right and it's like
the thing to do I think he actually
hurts the movement you know it's there
are people that hurt the movement sure
by being so crazy radical it doesn't
make sense to anybody who's just kind of
willing to listen to you but I mean it's
a hard life like uh I don't see why
anybody would actually choose it I mean
trans girls get the [__] beat out of
them they get like it's not an easy
existence um you know she and I go out
we're very it's much nicer than we
thought it would be do you have to worry
about like do you ever get in weird
situations where like safety is an issue
cuz she's trans no but when we travel I
the first thing I do is see is this a
place where it's good for us or not um
I'll never go to a place that probably
not going to Russia going to Chia never
I'll never go to any mdle a hard pass
yeah yeah you can't do it you know I
don't want to be some place that hates
our guts either like you're not doing me
a [__] favor by see I you know I like
the Burge Khalifa but you know if you
want to throw us off it I'd prefer not
to go there you look at pictures yeah I
mean there's nowhere I need to go but
yeah the safety is a concern but uh you
know you are a white belt though I am
yes so I could at least roll around if
somebody in a wheelchair attacked me I I
can [__] at this point grab one of
their [__] soft mey pliable legs
M pable leg put him in ankle I can't
feel title for this episode is soft mey
pliable
legs got him can't feel that arm what
you
got all right first one is Dana White
him talking about um you know there
there's a little Instagram clip so I'll
just play that for you guys I don't want
to speak too much on because that game
looks good Jesus does he a lot of way
yeah that that nutritionist is doing the
Lord's work man
he's I don't want to speak too much on
him because I don't know enough about it
but apparently there's a basketball team
up there that is incredible High School
uh high school or college team I'm not
sure um they're really good and they're
smoking teams the state is now going to
impose something on them they're going
to be penalized oh wow for blowing teams
out of the water uh as bad as they are
because they're too good is this in
California yet sounds perfectly in the
moment exactly what's happen you ever in
your [__] I mean it's just it's
unbelievable so I'm I'm going to reach
out to the coach oh you should of the
team out there and and see what I could
do if anything I want to bring that
whole team out to a fight in Las Vegas I
I want to I want to I want
to I want to reward these guys for being
such badasses when when these these
these these [__]
okay that that that that control
whatever League they're in or whatever
are trying to do this to him it's
disgusting and every one of you that are
involved in this in the state of Maine
that are imposing this thing on this
team you're you're you guys [__] make
me sick you are what's wrong with this
country now putting the sanctions on
have never played sport so of course
like this is UNF they're trying to
literally sanction them they're they do
it here too like my my son's team they
didn't want to keep score I bring a
scoreboard yeah
40 5-0 I don't I mean what are we doing
and we blame young people like like like
the whatever the new generation is it's
not their fault it's the [__] people
that are like below my generation in
their late 30s that that raised them
it's not it's don't blame young people
most of the time a lot of people our age
in the academic world were already
indoctrinated it's the people putting
the sanctions on like this type of thing
never played Sports and and then their
kids are probably really shitty at
sports so they want to make their kids
feel good or make their friends feel
good but it's Sports
dude I knew early on I wasn't good at it
you know why cuz I struck out a lot and
because I [__] hit a little squibber
up the first Baseline and my coach is
like run Jimmy and I'm like it's a foul
ball and then it went fair and I was
standing there with the bat and I got
thrown out and humiliated now imagine if
they had San on imagine if they had
sanct like all right when Jim's up we're
going to put a tea out as a kid you're
like proba like that if it was a te it's
it's it is a Marxist it's like it's like
let's make it equal and smart and the
way you make everybody equal is you take
the special people and you have to push
them
down lazy [__] parents who don't want
to explain to their kid hey losing with
dignity is okay too that's all it is
it's also ideologues it's ideolog what's
an ideologue an ideologue is somebody
who believes in an ideology like in a in
a fixed truth that is not responsive to
evidence it's really a form of a
religion it's a form of a religion
without a Transcendent truth his son is
a his son is seven and weighs as much as
my 12-year-old and it's not fat no it's
it's all muscle and bone kind of look at
the size of him he's on steroids yeah
he's he's tall enough and very Strong's
EPO man very
athletic yeah he could do the slap Fight
League but can't fight in the UFC yeah
yeah not yet you know I'm doing UFC no
hell no I tell them kid no like uh I
fought in the UFC because I had no
options kids with options don't fight in
the UFC right no it comes as as Mike
Tyson says it comes from the gutters
like you got to have yeah you're not
growing up with your dad driving what I
drive fighting the UFC would you want
him to fight like say in just pure
Jiu-Jitsu tournaments that's like same
yeah he loves Jiu-Jitsu loves wrestling
I'd let him do that but as far like it's
a tough gig man it's tough and it it's
again this is a knock on Dana but as far
as like the the fighter pay and stuff
it's just the juice isn't worth the
squeeze like our friends who were world
champions are screwed man [__] yeah
like horrible CT uh lost their jobs they
can't hold a job like alcohol problems
drug problems so it's it's just just not
worth the squeeze it's not like football
baseball yeah hell yeah it's worth the
squeeze you get some injuries you're
going to be compensated down the road
but UFC they just again it's not it's
not Dana's job I don't harp on Dana
anymore I I usually agree with
99.99% of things Dana says me and him
are I agree with him I have no issues
with them but when it comes to it's just
where it's at they're in leather helmets
if it's the NFL so the the conversation
is just not there yet so with my son
it's like no it's not worth it man it's
too much work yeah plus getting there I
mean plus there's a lot of fighting to
get there you're not just getting you're
not just signing up for the UFC getting
a great contract you got to fight on the
regional circuit and if if you know
maybe you make it maybe you don't it's a
yeah and there's yeah there's a more of
a blueprint now than when I was fighting
like they have the Dana White Contender
series now so it's like you start in a
regional circuit whether it's in Jersey
or California you fight in the LFA you
become champed there then hopefully you
get invited to the ultimate fighter or
to the Dana White Contender series then
you earn your contract on there then
you're in UFC but then the work starts
that's what people don't realize it's
same with the NFL like just cuz you're
in the NFL you're not balling like you
got to get to that second contract in
UFC you got to get to that second I
didn't start making money I get to my
second contract by the way I just uh
just to point out what just happened
here is I as a fat tited white belt just
explained to a former UFC fighter the
path to the UFC fact that you didn't get
up and plant your foot in my face uh it
shows that you're a very nice person if
you would have kicked me in my
[__] doesn't matter I shouldn't have
said it here's how you get to the UFC
shut the [__] up tits I love I love the
other thing I like about Jim is he hates
himself as much as I hate myself so I
appreciate yeah I hate myself accurately
I just report what I say the fact that I
just did that andely went on to happened
you can do no wrong brother I ask if you
and your wife fight like me and my wife
so yeah it's a fair question you could
have slapped me in the face no I never
mind that I've had uh I had a former I'm
not going to say what weight class but a
former UFC champion not being a dick was
asking like bro do she have a dick like
they like there's people who are rude
and there's people who just don't know
anybody else in this type of L and ask
and it's like I'm yeah you could tell
when someone's asking a real question
when someone's being horrible I don't
mind the questions are fine but how much
have you learned from doing a a UFC pod
with Matt Sarah you know I I love
Fighters I and Matt is Matt is the
probably the most genuine guy he's very
much like henzo and I don't know henzo
nearly as well but they're freight
trains like they're henzo is a freight
train of energy like you can't not look
at him when he's in the room you can't
not listen they demand attention just by
being himself Matt is the same way it's
this [__] barreling freight train
100% genuine y like I I mean what he
says whatever the [__] he wants if he
doesn't like something he can't pretend
he does you know what I mean he you know
Matt is just 100% real person he's one
of my favorite people I've ever known
and just doing the show with them have
you has it make you love the UFC more
when you see how the hot dog's made are
you little like all right no I love it
more because it's so just training the
in the eight months I've been training
like I used to always have Fighters put
me in moves but I would just to see like
I I know you watch this stuff I wonder
what does it feel like yeah and the
first one to do was BJ Penn put me in an
arm bar and I never felt it before and I
was realizing I'm being pulled in two
different directions like you don't get
that from watching it disconcerting it
[__] hurts and they were being gentle
I wasn't he's not a big guy but a guy
like that puts his hands on you and
you're like oh I'm I'm walking around I
am an absolute gazelle among Lions but
Kane put me in a guillotine that hurt um
and [__] Jon Jones hurt me he put me
it was like fight we was cutting weight
bad time to ask someone to do a [__]
leg kick and he put his giant Jon Jones
Shin in my thigh oh my God and I had to
go to the bathroom cuz I thought I was
going to vomit but I almost [__] my
pants I'm not kidding it was like my
body just said it was like in shock and
it was like I was probably just kind of
whacked you a little it when you watch
him do it it was nothing like he could
have done it do you guys do anything
live around the events do you have
before but they put us in these weird
loud uh like we interviewed Luke rockle
and I forget who else we interviewed but
it was in this loud out like venue with
fans doing signings they don't
specialize in podcasts yeah it's got to
be a smaller venue but uh yeah I love I
love these guys I've talked to all of
them as I'm sure you have and they're
all they're all just nice guys they none
of them are dicks I've never had a
fighter be a dick to me no you won't
find one yeah most of them are great
humbling yeah and also it's too hard
it's just [__] hard same with Comics
like you won't find a lot of dick Comics
like most of it's too hard too hard of a
gig raised a point uh which I thought
was a good point in the comparison of
you're humbled constantly when you're
fighting you're always being tapped in
the gym you're always being submitted uh
and when you're doing comedy jokes are
always not working you're always but
there's always a thing that reminds you
of DUS puya said that I said to him what
drives you he said I'm I I always keep
my student mind I'm a student I'm always
a student I'm always learning yeah I
stay a student yeah knowing where you
stand really helps like hey there's
always people better than me I mean in
our field especially like there's people
who are a lot better than me and there's
people who are a lot more successful
than me uh and there's people that used
to open for me that are selling 16,000
seats don't get me wrong I'm happy for
them um couldn't be
happier I mean why would I be why would
I be unhappy for someone 16,000 seats
that's a lot of too much for comedy
that's what I say I intimacy I I read a
stat because Billy Joel performed last
night for first time in 30 years and
they were giving off his stats he sold
mass square Garen out 150 times what
times the arena Mas 150 my head I was
just about the money I'm like he's
balling I just listen to his newest song
It's amazing oh makes me sad right well
he had to his brother was his brother
brother-in-law someone in his family
took a lot of his money had to go back
on tour yeah he had something happened
to him where he gots manager right yeah
his business manager was that who was
yeah I'm blaming his family it was his
father stole it I don't know who it was
like last night they're like Billy Joel
performed for the first time 30 years
I'm like oh hell yeah is he going to do
some of the hits and like new song I'm
like [__] he's been on you liked it
right he did aeny what before the lights
go down he's been performing a lot you
mean the first news song yeah first in
30 years in 30 years but um you're
talking about a guy 130 songs of just I
mean what were you saying J he's been
performing a like at the are you saying
that I'm lost his first live performance
in 30 years they said no he's been doing
the garden every week or every month he
had a residency there recently maybe it
was his first new material that might
have been it cuz so he's been at the
Garden no but sold out Bubba yeah yeah
sold out make no mistake ladies and
gentlemen that's like you too right now
at uh in Vegas Las Vegas that that show
was oh insane yeah I saw Billy years ago
we had the same agent at one point
personal appearance uh because they only
did musicians so I got a nice ticket to
see him and Elton John and he took us
back to me him me and Bob Kelly and he
just sits there and eats Fisherman's
friends in between sets it was bizarre
to watch what a guy does for the voice
like I guess that he was just chewing
them one after the other after the other
Fisher friends oh those really sharp
cough drops they're like very oh I know
what you're talking about heavy [__]
Menthol yeah they're they're intense
cough drops yeah but I guess it's it's
good to smooth out the voice if you need
74 years old still doing it yeah they're
delicious actually I like a good
Fisherman's friend yeah or buley is a
good cough medicine their motto is it
tastes awful and it works I'll take
Canadian buy yeah uh he was saying Billy
Joel was saying he was like he was
toring for so long he just fell like
fell out of love with it from the tour
life travel life he's like I'm done I do
York I think he needs money now I'll
drive to Long Island I'll just
helicopter right a helicopter from the
Long Island Sound yeah 150 shows mascare
Garden God that dude is but I love his
music man I've always been a huge I know
every one of his songs by heart probably
just cuz a kid I was like this guy's
[__] Colin Quinn is not a fan of
Billy Joel uh so what I like doing is
occasionally I'll catch Uptown Girl or
something on the radio and I'll let to
just take a little video and said what's
the line he hates the most and it ruined
the song for me um uh uh tell her all
your crazy dreams and tell her about it
I'm like I hate that song though some of
those songs are the worst but the the
songs like from songs in the attic and
stuff those songs are great yeah I enjoy
Billy I think down Easter Alex is a
great song Easter Alex is a great song I
wrote that for the fishermen Long Island
who are going out of business I happen
to love Billy Joel but it's just fun to
me that Colin does that's a hell of a
song in 50 shows dude yeah it's pretty
impressive right insane I'm impressed
when Comics do it cuz Comics got to do
different material every time like
that's the like you look at Sebastian
Maniscalco who's doing like he adding a
fifth show at the Garden that fucker's
got to have a different hour every year
like 100% singers have to have their
voices Sebastian's always worked his ass
off he's got that Italian work ethic
yeah musicians can play the hits and get
out they can play hour hits Sebastian to
do a new hour he's up there banging out
a new
hour and Bill same thing any of these
guys that are doing you can get away
with it more Club because a lot of times
it's people who are just going to the
club anyway but if they're going to the
Madison Square Garden they're going to
see all the time what El you impressive
[__] yeah it is it's a lot of bad sets
too I'm sure getting there a lot of
[__] tank jokes and you know J
working on material yeah so Joe Rogan
just signed a $250 million expansion
deal with Spotify it's brilliant What
Spotify is doing so you know what
they're doing so before was just
exclusive on Spotify but now they're
paying Joseph A Truck ton of money but
yeah Joseph
of money but now they're going to get
their money back off the ads so now it's
going to be on Spotify YouTube regular
YouTube so it's brilliant because it
builds the audience and then they reap
all the benefits from the ads and Rog
gets his flat fee it's brilliant when
Rog I don't care who you are obviously
Joseph's a huge uh friend but when he
goes to Spotify I know a lot of people
that stop listening just because they
don't they can't keep up with
it hear stat so on
Spotify so the the 20% of all listeners
are listening to Joe Rogan on Spotify so
if you're on Spotify so if somebody's
listening to Spotify anywhere in the
world there's a one in five chance
they're listening to Joe R it's crazy
you know it's crazy but think about they
signed Dak Shepard caller daddy a ton of
shows remember they're just forking over
so much money Rogan's the only one they
resigned yeah that's right that's right
yeah I guess it's a hard business model
to
keep he's got some crazy magic because
Lex Freeman's getting 1 million uh
modern wisdom's getting 500,000 the
different like you know big they pulled
it back before they given
out he's averaging 13.5 million listens
13.5 I mean it's crazy it's crazy that's
just on the first he's like hanging out
with a politician now yeah yeah like we
go to restaurant Security's like he's
coming through like Jesus Christ dude I
know I was like congrats on the deal
he's like thanks brother it's like just
like I don't know what to say I'm like
you're you're good you're a billionaire
you know yeah it is Walker what you say
to somebody unless you're worth 150
million and they got 250 million then
you're like ah good one but when you're
you know I guess there's a point where
it doesn't matter but I also think it
kind of sucks for him that they report
the money my friend I hate when like the
NBA or NFL when they report like Patrick
Mahomes getting whatever 850 million or
otani's getting 700 million it's like
could you just say big contract like
sign 10e like do you have to leak their
info cuz you got the snakes out there
like Rogan's friends the haters like I
just do you have to leak exact numbers
them to leak Joe's numbers than what I'm
making uh I would prefer that than the
humiliation of what I'm doing a club for
hear you yeah man it never ends if you
make 250 million you don't mind people
knowing it either especially if you got
security and you know yeah you own guns
here's another 250 mil yeah it's good to
see one more yeah one more okay
cool this one here this is so dope Shane
Gillis is going to be hosting SNL if you
guys remember he had the shortest SNL
contract fired one day fired the next
because of a little bringing him back
here's what's crazy is the how Full
Circle Shane Gillis is so much bigger
inside life they need him when before
they fired him now he's bigger than they
are his shows get more views his skits
that he does gets more views in sat and
by the way I will Pat myself on the back
I did call this recently that they were
going to hire him uh it was a smart move
and he's doing so well and he and he
really he just did it in spite of the
fact that they it's [__] it's amazing
and I like the fact that people rallied
around that I like that the fans went
[__] this me too this guy's funny me too
and he also signed with Bud Light yeah
yeah yep yeah Shane's crushing it man
yes he is there's like a new crop out
there in New York right it's like the
Tim Dylan Chrissy D's Tim is out but
Chris D Schultz those guys Tim started
in New York right Tim started in York
with you guys so you got Tim Schultz D
Stefano uh Mark Norman is killing
[__] Sam Mill is hilarious Lane is
[__] a monster great and he sells out
theaters um yeah there's a lot of guys
that young crops CR doing very well yeah
but they're all funny and like when they
go people go back and see them again
because the material is good they're all
working out at the seller like they're
all working I see just five nights a
week they're all working on material
none of them are just showing up doing
the same thing year after year they're
all working on material got to be doing
that yeah it's nice to see perfect shout
out to Shane Gillis man is that it Jun
that's it look at that [__] picture by
the way it's not the photographer's
fault at all it's a picture that was not
meant to be that way I look so fat I
have lost a few pounds I think you look
great you're a good friend I am such an
egg-headed pig boy better you're I think
you're an important person for comedy
and I think you're an important person
for the Zeitgeist and I just I find you
to be a breath of [__] fresh air so
thank you Brian keep doing what you're
doing I will and and and it's always
nice to see that there are curtains that
can still be pulled across the back rows
of theaters and comedy clubs like thank
God for curtains that's what I should
have invested in
Rich newon theater you're at the Newton
theater Newton New Jersey Mystic Theater
you're doing theaters real theater
Golden State Theater comedy Mothership I
love it yeah bunch of stuff out here I
got Austin Houston Dallas um and we just
added some stuff so yeah I'm happy the
tour is is good I just hope people come
out and see it it's a new hour of
material they definitely should brother
I hope so and then we got live fireing
the kid announcing at life firing the
kid in Aus Texas Austin Texas get your
tickets February 15th F special guest
very special guest February only
um wow wow I'm sorry I missed that one
wow change that that's when the notebook
it was back when the notebook that's
exactly goling it will be there and
nobody knows him we're gonna get in the
time machine it's gonna be great guys
it's Notting I'm at the well Bakers
field with Sam tripley then the recck
rooms March no it's February 24th oh my
yeah February 24th [__] dude yeah I'm
gonna kill Nick all right Louisville
comedy club and Bricktown Comedy Club
brian.com all right kids kid live Vulcan
gas theater uh one show only February
15th that's coming up soon Jim we love
you man I love you guys thank you can I
just plug Nikki and Jim NYC if you want
to see what I'm doing with my wife and
thank you guys for having me I really
love this thank you you were awesome
that was awesome